Oh, hello, sorry, I'm sorry, yay, welcome to 2026, new year,
same old dokey, sorry, I'm all over the place right now, um,
I didn't look at my, I didn't look at my go XLR and saw
myself muted, I forgot pressed the muted button for VR chat,
but, um, I'm back, guys, hello, welcome back, same old
dokey, new year, same old dokey, um, some things just never
change, so, eating i'm also eating my dinner lunch today
right now like literally like right now uh my my uber eats
order guy delivery guy was late uh with my food it took him
much longer than i expected to to get my food um literally
arrived like 10 minutes before the stream was supposed to
start i was like okay guess i'll i'll eat on stream i'm so
hungry my stomach is growling um
Um, no, I didn't have anything to eat last night, um,
because I was busy, like, prepping for everything, so I was
just like, do I eat before, because I didn't want to get,
like, a tummy ache when I'm doing my VR chat thing, um, so
that's why I was like, oh, I'll just eat, I'll eat, like,
after the stream, and then obviously I passed up right after
the stream, and then I slept for, like, 10 plus hours.
Also, um, so we're just gonna eat, I'm, we're just gonna eat
a little bit before we go through the behind the scenes of
Tokyo!
though I would like to have some food in my stomach before
we go over everything because it's a lot of stuff like I
said this project took half a year um to come to life um and
uh has to be I will say this is the most expensive VR chat
world I've ever funded it was uh it's because like we like
they built it from the ground up so um so there was a lot of
people working on this um almost every day i'm having
hibachi but i'm not ordering from this place again it's not
the best hibachi place i wanted to try this new hibachi
place and i was like it's not very good i can't believe i
ordered from the one hibachi place that's like westernized
hibachi it's not like
like where there's more it's like westernized hibachi where
there's a a lack of flavor so like not enough you know like
okay Asian hibachi is basically where they just drenched the
entire thing with the sauce like the hibachi sauce like the
sweet sauce um they lack the sauce for this one so um so i'm
not very happy about that yeah i lost the Hibachi got you.
I, you know, I was like, you know what?
First day of the year?
Surely it's going to go well, right?
Surely, surely, you know, my first meal of the year would be
okay.
I should have had a feeling.
I should have had, okay, the thing is, I should have had a,
okay, I usually go to this other Hibachi place, which is
like my favorite childhood Hibachi place, but I wanted it
fast, you know, because I was just like, I'm so hungry.
And I literally woke up like, you know, I woke up 30 minutes
before the supposed stream time, which was 1 p.m.
So I was just like, um, uh, like I was just like, I need to
push it up the stream.
I'm too tired.
And I haven't even made the waiting room thumbnail at all.
Uh, because I told my thumbnail maker, I was like, you don't
have to make the thumbnail for the behind the scenes one.
I got it.
Don't girl, I got it.
I can do it myself.
And I was like, I don't got it right now.
and I want it fast so I was like okay this this hibachi
place is much closer than my go-to place which I've always
ordered when I was uh since my uh since I was a child um so
I was just like okay I'll try this place out and then I
should have had a okay there were several red flags
but but the biggest red flag was they still they are um the
hibachi place sells chicken wings like the hot wings and i
was just like that's weird but i was like you know what i'm
craving some hot wings right now as well i might as well
order hot wings with my hibachi i was like i was like i i
should have known that was a red flag i was like that's
weird that they would have hot wings with hibachi um hibachi
is basically like you know this like the hot stove thing
they do um and then they do like those like cha cha cha cha
like those like sticks not sticks um those metal uh grill
things where they're they do hacha cha cha cha and then they
like do they do these like tricks on there with the rice and
be like i wish i just realized you can't see my hands i i
was doing the the spatulas those metal spatulas those metal
spatulas and then they like they two metal spatulas and then
they like toss and turn the food the the meats and the rice
and stuff yeah uh they cook on like a griddle in front of
you yeah that's hibachi and good there's place there's good
hibachis and then there's bad hibachis so i don't know what
benihana is i assume that oh i know that from solar
opposites benihana is like a famous hibachi place in america
um so that's it's basically Nihana um so yeah I ordered
hibachi I assume it was like the Asian more Asian like
hibachi then I I saw the red flag where they were selling
hot wings with hibachi and then I was just like I want hot
wings but usually the meat is teriyaki meat like it's
teriyaki sauce with with like you know chicken or beef or or
shrimp and stuff like that and so I was just like You know
what?
It's weird that they sell hot wings at this hibachi place,
but also I'm really craving some hot wings right now.
So, it's not just like, oh, fuck it.
Let's go.
Let's try this out.
But they definitely slacked on a teriyaki sauce.
I can barely taste any teriyaki sauce on my hibachi.
Because usually in hibachi, they like drench it with like
teriyaki sauce.
They called it yum.
What the fuck is yum yum sauce, by the way?
They're like, it comes with teriyaki sauce and yum yum.
yum sauce.
I'm like, what the fuck is yum yum sauce?
I've never heard sauce called like that before.
Yeah, it must be like some westernized way, some western,
like it has to have like some Asian name and they just call
it yum yum sauce.
There must be an Asian name to this.
There's no way it's actually called yum yum sauce there's no
way
i'm so confused i was so confused anyway let me take more
bites of mine
take more bites than my food real quick but i will say the
stream would be more relaxed doesn't remember the last
stream today um because like you know last two the last
month of december was a lot so i'm gonna this stream will be
much more relaxed and chill right now it's very informal um
we are going to go behind the scenes but i do want to just
hang out with you guys right now um let's see um handsome
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you happy new
year doki today is my birthday i just want to congratulate
you and the team for all the hard work in creating donkylon
proud to be a dragon and i found such a passionate creative
person thank you thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you and happy birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday dear handsome happy
birthday to you yeah happy birthday and some yo-bos yeah oh
my god the first birthday of the year
give the super chat thank you thank you no it's actually
called yum yum sauce it's an asian fusion thing with nor in
north america it's basically burger sauce with site spices
to better complement asian food what the this is the first
time i've ever heard of yum yum sauce i i like the other
hibachi place that i always go to never had yum yum sauce so
i am so confused that's a real thing That's a fucking real
thing.
I assume it was like an Asian sauce that they just like
Americanized.
That burger sauce with like, what?
All right, no.
Okay, so that's my second red flag.
If I see yum yum sauce, I...
If I see yum yum sauce, I most likely will not order from
that place.
I just, I don't know.
It's just, I don't want burger sauce on my fucking rice, I
guess.
It's just weird.
I don't want burger sauce when I'm eating rice Burger sauce
is supposed to be on burgers But it's so good I can barely
taste anything on this I can barely taste like any sauce on
this Boom It's mayo, ketchup, garlic, and a couple other
things Mmm Oh yeah Oh, yeah, the reason why I had to loop is
because as I was about to get ready, I got a text from my
landlord and I was like, remember to pay rent.
Because it's January 1st.
And I was like, oh, shit, okay.
That's why we were looping because I was trying to pay rent.
It was like, you still haven't paid January for, uh, put
your rent for in January 1st.
And I was just like, oh, fuck, okay, let me go.
Happy New Year.
And I was like, oh, fuck, let me go pay rent.
I want to get like, I want to make him angry because he's a
really good landlord.
Like, you know how he's a really good landlord?
He doesn't text me unless it's for rent.
That's why he's like, he's like, literally he doesn't ask
for anything.
He's just like, he only texts me if I, if I like, if I
forget to like, pay rent a day.
like my debt my rent payment is literally the first day of
every month but um usually he just wants to make sure that
he's gonna get it on the first day so if I don't I usually
schedule it um because like uh you know it's just more
convenient I just schedule my rent um the date like the day
before I just schedule it and obviously yes the day before I
was so busy with New Year's stuff I forgot to schedule my
rent payment so it goes automatically on the first like on
the first the next day uh midnight midnight hit and i didn't
get it so um so grandma pay rent and i was like oh shit okay
let me go manually send the rent money right now no no i
can't send a reoccurring i fucking hate my bank i
can't i tried i tried and i can't
Do I have to, I literally have to manually, I have to
manually pay my rent.
And I always have to remind myself.
Yeah.
Yeah, new year, new bank, exactly.
But yeah.
He's a really good landlord, though.
He doesn't...
he doesn't bother me at all he just literally was like only
talks to me when he needs money when he needs money
so the only time he talks to me and that's how i like it
don't need to do any small talk
what a cool guy
oh yeah okay okay let's ooh okay i gotta try some i haven't
had ranch with my wings a long time all right let me try
these hot wings oh let me try these hot wings let's see how
hot these wings are i'm pretty sure it's not that
hot guys so there was like a listing of like how hot you
want your wings and it's like mild medium Obviously, I
picked the hot version.
It's not that hot.
I mean, it has a kick to it.
I think me eating so much Bulldog Junos over the years has
fucked up my spice tolerance.
It's not that hot, though.
That's a small kick.
It has a kick.
Not a small kick.
It has a kick to it.
But, like, my tongue's okay.
It's, like, not that hot.
I feel... I think this would be medium.
I think this would be a medium.
I mean, when I did the, what is it called?
The Hot Wings Sauce Test?
The Hot Ones Test?
Like, their hottest sauce was alright.
Like, I mean, their hottest, hottest sauce, I was like,
yeah, no, that's spicy.
But, like, the other ones, before then, I was like, no,
that's alright.
Like, it's not that bad.
I don't understand, like, when you see them start crying and
stuff, I'm like, it's not.
I personally, I didn't think, like, it's, like, crying
material.
Because I had some crazy hot sauces before.
But,
yeah, the last, that's what I was saying.
The last dab was, like, the hottest one.
I was like, yeah, the hottest hottest one was hot.
Was a hot sauce.
There's one that literally tasted like fucking metal.
I was like, it's not even good hot sauce.
Like, the thing is, like, in Chinese cuisine, we literally
eat dishes just drenched with chili oil.
Like, my favorite, the mapwatering chicken.
like that's my favorite that's my favorite um chinese dish
and it's literally chicken just drenched in chili oil and
it's so fucking good yeah no there is a hot sauce and the
hot ones that literally just tasted like i'm fucking
drinking metal it doesn't even taste good
that's i fucking love chili oil
bomb?
Yeah, fuck that hot sauce.
That's not even good hot sauce.
It doesn't make it taste good.
Like, at least, like, make it taste like something.
I don't even remember if it's hot.
I just remember it tasted like shit.
Okay.
Well, before we begin, I'll show you guys the 3D model
stuff.
Alright, let me grab uh let me show you guys I'll grab I
didn't prepare I didn't like prepare a lot I didn't prepare
some of these so I'm just grabbing them as I go I know very
professional I'm just gonna I'm just gonna grab these
pictures as I go instead of like having them guys I passed
out right after I was I did not prepare behind like Like, a
huge shout-out to the project team for preparing a
PowerPoint of the behind-the-scenes stuff and all the
work-in-progresses and the concept art.
There's a lot.
There's a lot of slides.
But for the other stuff, outside of Doki Land, I didn't grab
any of the concept art, the behind-the-scenes, the
work-in-progress shots of everything.
I'm just going to go straight to it.
Like I said, first stream of the year.
I'm um relax hangout time we're just chilling it's been we
we just survived the summer and I'm just gonna chill right
now so bam uh here's shout out to the artist uh katsune I
think it's katsumi let me grab the artist real quick so you
guys know I'm gonna have the credits real quick no I know I
save that okay I did not save it I was like don't worry guys
I know I saved the credits I didn't save
it I so yeah I have it here um so let me just show the all
right so the wonderful people that worked on the 3d sub uh
katasumi was the concept artist so she uh he basically did
the um the i guess the three view of what the model is gonna
look like and then ryu and rika did the 3d design so we they
split in half so i think uh ryu made my 3d model but i don't
remember who made which were the other girls because my
point of contact was Ryu.
So I know Ryu made mine because he made the one before as
well.
So mine was the first one.
So he made mine first.
So they split the work in half with Rika as well.
So this one is my model.
This one's mine.
Oh, I'll show you what it looks like in 3D.
Translated in 3D.
It's so cute.
Let me grab it real quick.
It's actually, it looks so good.
Like, it actually, it's like one to one to the 2D
illustration.
We haven't listened to this in a while.
Alright.
Whoops.
Alright, it's almost one to one to the 2D illustration.
It looks so good.
It really does look really good.
Yeah.
That's what it looks like.
I will say, we did hit like a week before, a week before the
the debut of Jokulon.
This is not what it looked like before because I changed the
entire face of the previous model.
I wanted it to show on stream, but I forgot to because, you
know, a lot of other stuff was going on.
but the face originally did not look like that um i wanted i
realized when when they finished everything at the same when
everything was done and they were showing me all the all the
models together with all the other sloppy sisters mine
looked so different compared to everyone else because mine
was the first one and as they kept making it um the design
you can tell you sort of tell you can tell from here and the
reference sheet it's also like because they were following
the reference sheet so because the artists made mine first
um they focused more on the uh they focused more on the um
on i guess like matching my uh my skin suit design uh but i
was like oh i wanted to match the other girls more because
it looked so different in comparison put everyone out at the
same time.
So I was asked them if they could change the face to sort of
match the cohesive group of the sloppy sisters.
So I'll show you guys what I mean on what the face looked
like before.
So I could find the picture.
There it is.
Because I wanted to make it more soft.
I guess like cuter.
I wanted it to be cuter.
So you here it is so this was the face whoa whoopsie so this
was the face before and then you can tell like the eyes are
much more sharper and rectangular and i've thought like
compared to the other girls when we're all like put together
like side by side it just looked so off like i was just like
i still have i still have the model and also the shading of
the hair was different too because the other girls they had
a more the shading was more detailed in the back of the hair
so i was like asking if they could add that in as well
because i felt it i just looked like out of a bit out of
place um compared to the others so we had to like fix the um
we had to like fix the face last minute because i wanted all
of us to be more like a cohesive unit because like when we
were all put together side by side i stuck out so much like
it just it just looked like a little too off so I'm glad
that they were able to fix it I like the current face more
just because I think it's just cuter because it's supposed
to be like you know uh semi-cheby model can you get side by
side I mean this is the side by side the only difference is
literally the face guys like everything else is the same
like This is the side-by-side.
This is literally the side-by-side.
More side.
Oh, you mean like with the other girls?
Okay, I'll show you guys.
Let me see if I can actually, because I like grabbed all the
pictures together.
I was like, I don't know.
I'll show you guys what I meant.
I can screenshot it.
okay here you go um a snippet from our discord conversations
here do you have the insides
here so um don't mind the first one that was just me asking
for shading more shading on the hair as well so you can see
what i meant i was not like it just i've just felt like it
looked really off when we put all four of them together with
the older eyes so because of that i was like oh maybe we
should add like i wanted the eyes to be a bit more softer um
yeah so yeah but then the thing is everyone else sort of
matched together but then mine was like it just mine just
looked like always like just very different compared to
everyone yeah
so that's why i asked them to like adjust the i also didn't
like how rectangular there's just something off about it and
i didn't like how rectangular the eyes were too um so the
four sister came out evil be careful of the four sloppy
sister fair but i'll show you like what it looks like
afterwards i think um let me see i didn't make a thing here
afterwards just to give me like a point of reference
but i do have it uploaded the the model with the sharper
eyes i do have it on file like in vr chat it's not like it's
gone forever but I personally prefer the softer ones here I
think the softer one just looks a lot cuter in my opinion
and I like the edit for it
hmm and it only just matches everyone a lot better
hmm anyway let me grab the other letters references too what
is
I'm really happy to work with her again, though.
I keep seeing her when the artist is a guy, but I guess it's
just...
The artist is just so cute, so, like, how do you go with...
I don't know.
In my head, I'm just like, oh, my God.
And his icon is, like, a cute girl, too.
So, then, I'm, like, her.
I was accidentally using her, like, she and her.
Because the icon's a cute anime, girl.
Okay, and this is Mint's reference.
Oh my gosh, this is a big-ass fucking file.
I mean, resize it, guys.
Don't worry.
Almost done.
And this is Mint Ventome!
This is her reference sheet.
It's so cute.
I love how everyone came up.
And, um...
This is Mint's reference.
Um, like I said, um, I paid for...
Everyone, I... Everyone's there, like, are you sure?
Everyone's like, are you sure, Doki?
And I was just like, no, just take it as, like, a Christmas
gift, you know?
Um, there...
I just figured, like, you know, a Christmas gift to the
Sloppy's.
Hmm.
Um.
Wait, that's her reference sheet.
That's not the LAMS reference sheet.
That's her.
That's her actual reference sheet.
Oops.
Alright.
And then there's Lamun's uh
there's Lamun's reference.
And then...
Where is Snuffy?
And then this is...
Yeah, they all came out really, really cute.
And this is Snuffy's reference sheet!
Yeah!
And we are getting all of these...
I guess like rigged for stream as well, like non-VR streams.
Because they have to have a special rigging done.
Like AR kit and stuff.
Those the girls are paying individually.
Because.
My Christmas gift for some models.
Not the rig.
Not the AR kit.
Because the AR kit is also very expensive.
So I was like.
If you guys want to use it.
Non-VR chat.
I'm sorry.
You guys have to pay for it yourself.
Yeah.
So.
Oh yeah.
Also the legs were.
Like this is what the legs are.
on the artwork um so yeah but all the girls are paying for
them for the the non um how expensive is ar kit i just
remember it being expensive because like it takes a lot of
work too because it has to be matched the the face rigging
of your like the face movement and everything
so i was just like yeah i'm sorry girls you'll have to pay
for if you want to use this outside of VR chat, outside of,
I guess, like 3D.
I mean, technically, like, it's still 3D, but, you know, if
you want to use it, like, actually, like, streaming-wise,
outside of VR chat, you'll have to pay for the rigging for
that.
And you guys can see the legs are really skinny in the 2D
one, in the art references.
I had to ask the modelers to make their legs a little
thicker because I was like, yeah, it might be a little too
skinny.
I was like, so we actually, on the 3D models, we actually
like plumped the legs a little bit more, just a little bit
because I figured, I thought that, I don't know, I thought
it was just a little too skinny when I saw it in motion.
Um, when I saw it in motion and everything, um, here's
something fun that I can show you guys.
Let me download this video real quick.
known YouTube video.
Doing it all live.
Juge, they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
Halabra, they give us a super chat.
Doki, the sisters collab.
The sloppy sisters collab in Doki Lan was adorable.
It looked a lot like an elementary school field trip.
Yeah, like we're going to the Westworld.
Next, get someone with Miss Frizzle style model.
Here's set.
Thank you.
We're fucking heading the Westworld right now
What art is it called like there's like Reenactment places
that they they could take their kid like take the kids to
during school trips because there's like separate different
kinds I know there's one where it's like a reenactment of
like the uh The old days Frontier land is that what it's
called?
No, not LARPing.
Like, you know, like where you take the kids, the kids to,
like, school trips for, like, reenactments of, like, history
stuff.
Like, there's, like, the Wild West reenactments, and then
there's, like, ones where, because I remember in Canada,
they took me to one where it wasn't medieval.
Like, it was, like, like, the Gold Rush era in Canada.
I don't remember what it's called and during that his like
what was the time frame around those around that when was
the gold rush like those mini villages the heritage oh is it
a heritage village I guess so I think that's what they're
called yeah but Dokilan is basically that it's basically
Westworld late yeah the early 1800s early 1900s The pioneer
villages.
Yeah, shit like that.
That's basically Doki Land.
The happiest place on earth.
Oh yeah.
Uh...
What is this file?
Oh, it's the...
Okay.
I'll show you guys a video.
I think there's no sound here.
Yeah.
There you go.
Here's Mint Dancing.
There's the 360 of me.
movement moving while we were testing the we were they were
testing how the models are moving
there she goes look her dance whoa there she fucking goes
guys whoa look at her move but yes that's how that's how I
guess like flexible they are
Anyway, there's me.
I need to download the video of me too.
Wait, is this the same?
Oh, wait, this is an old video.
I have to download a new video of it.
Look at that movement!
Truly new year movement right there.
Alright, let me grab the other files of the moving.
Oh yeah, you guys weren't able to see Lime was expressions
too.
I'll grab that.
badmose expressions as well.
This has to be the most unorganized behind the scenes, but
guys, you have to...
Please, I am...
But it's understandable why.
Why is this the most unorganized behind the scenes?
December was a lot for me.
It was a lot.
It has to be the most casual behind the scenes.
Do you play VR chat outside of stream?
Um, not really.
No, I don't.
I think it's just because VR is just too much stuff to put
on for VR.
It's very annoying.
Yeah, it's a chill stream.
Ah, but let me grab.
Here, here's Lamu's expressions that she wasn't able to show
you guys.
So, she has cried, shocked, annoyed dot eyes excited and
hard eyes those were her expressions that you guys weren't
able to see um let's see yeah what else oh yeah I wanted to
show you guys the I'll show you guys me moving but I don't
but let me find the video I'm gonna show that i'm moving too
because that's the first video i found that's the first
video that showed up so i will show that all right
downloading right now it's downloading i don't think i need
to show snuffy because she was so i think it's like she has
like a thousands of hours on vr chat so she knows how to be
like super expressive um in VR it's different motion capture
and VR is so different like movement wise because like in VR
everything is so much more clunkier because it's like you
know I have to hold on the controllers and also like the the
full body tracking is like they're like when when they're
very like I won't say fragile but when you're moving with
full body trackers because they're like to your waist.
They're strapped to your waist and your left and right foot,
like ankles.
And it's like, they're like these giant clunky triangular
things.
So when you're moving them, they like move around your body
too.
So it's like I have to always like adjust it because it's
like, it can like move like, it can like move out of
position and it's so annoying.
But when you're in like motion capture, it's like a lot
different I just realized it's like a lot different because
like I guess it's like since the suit is like a body suit
it's a body suit so you barely feel you barely like feel the
things on your body yeah I'm using vibe trackers
the thing is vibe trackers are much more uh accurate than
Moko B or body tracking.
You're doing like in-house 3D.
That's why they're so expensive.
Because vibe trackers are more expensive than than Mokapi.
Oh yeah, here is there's not moon dancing.
Okay, there you go.
Also, I realized I don't have the video of like the new face
so i have one of like the older face for mine
oh there she goes there she was and then there she goes now
this is mine
look at me girl look at that fucking movement i have no idea
what the fuck i'm dancing to i'm just i have no idea what
this dance She's ulting.
I definitely like the newer face.
I think the old face just feels off.
Well, I just look at the newer one now.
This is not a fortnight.
Technically, all dances are fortnight dances.
Oh my god, it's still going.
Everyone was so fast.
I'm pressing Q.
That's the average time span of a Luna ult, by the way.
Time to put on a show.
Is that really Luna's dancing?
What else?
What else I want to show you?
You know what?
I'll show you guys the world before I go to the behind the
scenes stuff.
I know it'd be fun.
Let me go to...
um i'm thinking of whether there's anything else i want to
show you guys from the 3d stuff i think that's it all right
let me show you guys the world i don't know i don't know the
game sound is gonna be really loud but we'll see we'll see
we'll show you guys don't get oh my god i almost went
straight to Rivals.
I was like, let's boot up.
And I hovered to Rivals.
I...
Whoops.
Alright, let's go to Doki Lon.
A number one Dragoon vacation spot.
It's just like Disneyland, but more expensive.
Grab.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who made them on?
How much did it cost?
It looks great.
I'll put up the credits again.
Grab it.
Where did I save it?
Not.
Oh, wait.
That's not it.
What the fuck was that?
Oh, it is.
Oh, my gosh.
This is a big-ass crit file.
I didn't even realize how big the file was.
All right.
So the people who made...
Oh, look, that's me.
Look, there I am.
That's me.
So, the people who made this is Katasumi, Ryu, and Rika.
Shout out.
Congratulations.
Sorry.
So, huge shout out to the three people who made this,
basically.
Price-wise, we don't talk about it.
We don't talk about the price.
It was, it was, it was something.
Okay, it got, like, even my manager was like, don't tell me.
Because I was like, because I told him my manager, I told
him, I was like, yeah, I paid for everyone's models.
And he was like, yeah, I thought so.
Please don't tell me how much it cost.
had a I had a feeling I had a feeling I I do not want to
know how much it cost and then because of how expensive
everything was getting he actually had to step in and
message everyone like message the server and everyone being
like look I know Doki said there is no budget but we're
gonna start putting a budget right now I know you guys had a
plan about like how you're gonna spend on everything but
looking at how much we're currently paying right now like
how much how much we've been paying so far for this world
and how much we're currently paying for i i have to step in
and negotiate a budget i felt so bad because i was like it's
okay guys no budget and then you have to step in and And I
was like, guys, okay, look.
There is going to be a budget now.
All right.
Let's see.
I need to boot up Toki-lon.
Because there's a lot of things I wasn't able to show you
guys.
I have so many tabs right now.
This is bad.
There's so many devs.
All right.
Launch world.
Join.
Yay!
Dokilad!
But yes, for those who don't know, the Sloppy Sisters are
doing an official meet and greet at Dokilad.
Welcome!
Dokilad!
Yay!
Oh my god, wait.
Yeah, I did a new thing.
That is a new thing where I can go stream camera.
I think?
Oh, I can't.
Never mind.
I thought I was like, oh my god, guys, I can do a stream
camera on desktop now.
I cannot do a stream camera on desktop, apparently.
Unlucky.
I thought we finally have rights.
top players finally have rights now unfortunately they do
not so i'll take this away all right let me i don't know if
we need more sound but i'll do it up the sound yeah look
like i said for future updates we're gonna make it so that
you can enter all of these houses so you might be able to
meet croaky merchant croaky and everything So there's more
wanted posters here Stuck at work prison There's more wanted
posters of everyone There's the billboards There's my ads
But there's like Oh yeah there's cactuses here Yeah The
banker dragoon We're gonna make it so I want to add like
We're gonna make it so that when you talk for future update
When you talk to the banker goon Each person gets their own
amount Like each person has a different amount when they
when they uh oh yeah you can be in these guys too wait let
me see where's the camera
look hello hello senora
look that's you now can we
Talk of me.
The Wild West regular.
Oh.
Look.
That's also me.
That's also you.
Oh my god.
See your tail's peeking out too.
Oh.
Wait, wait.
Someone.
Wait.
Let me change back.
I saw someone say something very important in my...
chat.
It's very important.
Nihadi.
It's neat.
Oh yeah, there's several different body pillows scattered
around the world.
Here, this one you guys might, this one I wrote.
You can tell which one I wrote and which one, um, the other,
uh, uh, the project team wrote.
Don't tell the sheriff that broke out of jail i don't want
to go back to the water prison they killed the local horse
in there that's right so we're gonna recreate my jail in the
next update you too can go to my torture chamber the gula
yeah and so these are more wanted posts oh yeah this guy's
my favorite this dragon was my favorite the croaky emporium
merchant come check out our wares at croaky's emporium and
also check out the merch store dokeymerch.com you can also
use the code dokeybridge for gamer subs fortnite and apex
wow we please buy her bridge please we have so doggy shirts
she started beating the bus this guy's my favorite he truly
is the showmaster here and he's at of course he's at the
fucking course he's at the entrance guys but where else
would he be where oh yeah you close the turn off oh yeah
there oh yeah these two used to be naked and I was like can
you please put clothes on them.
Lama's Snuffy's fans were naked.
I was like, can you please like put them on, like give them
some clothes and also like sticks?
On them.
I added him too.
I requested this guy as well.
You guys hear the BGM, right?
In real public nudity.
Sadly, this guy's naked, though.
This guy's naked.
The shark goons took all his money.
It's a bit low.
I gotta turn it up a little bit more.
Alright.
I'll turn it up more then.
Take a shot every time Doki abuses her power.
And look, he's sober, guys.
He's so...
Guys, he's so sober.
Look at that.
that's totally his name he's so so sober you guys oh yeah
all right it's the is audio better oh yeah here are some
games we didn't get through any look like the entire stream
was like finding mint phantom it's like saving point saving
mint phantome so we had to rush through a lot But there are
games.
There are games in this world.
This is one of them.
So, for this, it's like, here's a hammer.
And then...
Oh, wait.
I gotta start it.
It's like a whack-a-mole.
Boom.
Oh, that's so cool.
Yeah, it's whack-a-bullet.
There you go.
It's to test your reflexes.
Boom!
There you go.
Oh, I lost some life?
How?
Alright, this could go on forever.
But yeah, that is like one of the games.
Then we have our farmers here.
Welcome to tomato farm.
I raised those tomatoes from seeds.
I think you just walk in here with your grabby hands?
Pick my tomatoes?
Pick my tomatoes!
Also, you guys might have noticed, so it spawns in.
There's a chance for it to spawn in spawn in me.
So, look, see?
Look.
There's me.
Right here.
There's a chance you get tomatoes that spawn that spawn in
me in here, too.
So, you can pick them, and then maybe if you're lucky, you
can pick me.
See, there's more.
I see all there's different types of body pillows.
Oh yeah, we didn't get to talk to this guy.
It's time for Halloween!
Don't come to my house or else I suck your...
Oh, blood.
I suck your blood.
See?
What a good dragon.
And there's the crying...
The crying...
I-boos now.
And then I love this one.
When you get close to the grave...
A little...
A goon comes out.
It's like, boo!
I caught you!
Here are all the other names.
There's Tomatori, Pug Snuffy, RestoTuber 2025.
Slash kill at all.
The suspects.
Mockery.
Zendrea, Chibi-Doki, because this, I don't know if you guys
remember, but in the Bounty Hunter debut, I shot her.
This is where she lies.
This is like a throwback.
Rest in peace, lost the nap gadget.
Oh, you poor thing.
You fucking poor thing.
So that's why she's dead.
Don't tell her mom.
Oh, yeah, so for these coins.
You'll be able to collect them around the world.
There's seven to collect around the world.
So you'll be able to go around and collect those.
And then there's like little gotcha pawns.
You can use them though.
They're just for the split.
There's some cool gotcha pawns around here.
Yeah, there's collectibles.
I won't tell you where the others are though.
Oh, and then there's dad here.
Will you take this rose and be my next dog sitter?
A lovely rose for a...
A lovely rose for a lovely dragon.
It's our own little secret.
You and I...
I won't tell her what we did.
You get a little...
Achievement.
You get a little trophy.
Also, look at these cactuses.
Cacti.
It's shaped like you!
They're only shaped like you.
They're not actually you, guys.
We didn't turn you into cactuses.
Cacti's.
Don't worry, the misbehaving goons does not get turned into
cactuses.
Oh, and then there's a dunk tank.
Oh, I wish we did the dunk tank.
That would have been so fun.
Like I said, we had very limited time.
But there's a dunk tank right here.
You didn't dunk your fellow goons.
Oh, and there's more ads.
There's like fake ads around here, too.
There's some fun fake ads around here.
And graffiti as well.
where you guys can find all the graffiti.
There's also real ads.
See, there's like games here.
And...
Here, we can have actually played cards here.
So there's like a card game here.
I don't know what card... I think this is goldfish.
I have no idea.
Actually, I have no idea what card game this is.
I didn't have a chance.
Oh yeah, there's the broken monitor.
Here are all your game chat games.
Look!
I included some of your game jam stuff too.
Oh, throwback to you guys.
Oh, yeah.
Pouty.
What can I get you?
Whiskey, Dragon Shine.
You can grab some drinks here.
Look, and then there's me.
You be next to me.
And you play darts.
And there's some burgers.
There's lots of burgers.
You can steal the fries, too.
And there's a dragon here having fun time.
at detective dragon oh yeah you can play tomagun this is a
real game you can play you can play pond yeah skill diff oh
and this is my favorite rug where's the best commute okay
look i didn't have time okay oh yeah for this um feel free
to check out this book uh a bunch of um the project team uh
put in their comments in here They're like cute little
notes.
They're all so fucking cute.
Oh, and then there's a rice cooker.
I don't know why you guys keep...
I have...
This is the only place where you can get...
Where there's rice cookers.
Let's see.
Bottom, bottom.
Oh, yeah.
Some beautiful artwork.
And you're gonna play...
You're gonna play...
Crane games here too.
too this one's broken wait you can play them on non-desktop
mode okay that's a bug we gotta fix okay so we found our
first bug oh we found so um apparently a desktop mode uh you
cannot access you cannot activate the crane game on desktop
mode so oh there's another coin Yeah, but we'll get that
fixed.
We'll get that fixed.
Don't worry, guys.
We'll fix that.
Also, there's a EP Dragon.
EP.
ZZ-Z-Z.
For Doki.
Z-Z-Z.
Yay.
There's a lot of stuff I didn't show you guys yet, but I
want you guys to explore it yourself.
Let's show some fun things.
Just try out and explore it yourself.
But yeah, unfortunately, this area was not finished.
This is an actual gameplay area.
So we can break in technically.
You guys can break in and explore it.
But that's all it is.
It's just exploring.
But there will be.
There will be like.
Okay.
I just realized what was down there.
But.
But there will be like an actual like shooting game that you
play.
That's based off of the.
My bounty hunter debut.
The battle royale game mode.
It's not going to be Battle Royale, but it'll be like a team
game.
You're now under construction.
This is Doki will change in the Battle Birds.
I realized that was a big mistake that we...
Okay, it'll be like at the bottom.
There'll be a sign at the bottom and be like, Battle Birds.
Because the logo is sick, though.
There's a sick-ass logo, so it'd be a shame to hide the
logo.
But we'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
Please do come back another day when it's all finished.
But no trespassing allowed.
I'm watching you.
Stick him out.
Yeah, we'll fix it in post.
Yeah, but here.
See?
There's a cover and everything.
Look.
You can tell.
You can tell that this is cover.
Oh yeah, it's sort of like...
Yeah, see this team.
Team Tomato.
Oh, they even super chat.
They can think.
Yeah, so it's like everything you saw in the...
In the...
A bounty hunter debut.
Yeah.
You encountered all of this.
Whoa, I'm burning alive!
Whoa!
And then the other team is...
What is the other team?
Where's the place where the dragon died?
I'll find it.
And team Kroki.
There's Team Tomato versus Team Kroki.
Look, and I was here.
Doki was here.
Is this extraction?
Is this Arc Raiders?
Yeah, it was around here.
This is where they died.
I remember it was like here.
It was like, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
It was around here.
Yay.
there's like graffiti scattered every how do i go back oh
it's over here i was like how do i how do i go back yeah
that sucks there's all the ads you saw in the debut
there and then you can climb back up here you technically
actually try to climb back by just using the ladder but it's
very hard
it's very hard i can't do it that's what they told me but i
i ain't bothering with that i'm just gonna click on it but
yeah looks amazing everyone worked so hard in this world i
can't wait to update it even more yeah you can technically
skyrim it and everything the easter eggs too like we we get
hopscotch too we there was a lot of concepts we had to cut
because look i have my own hollywood sign doke lawn you guys
like look at that happiest place on earth i even have my own
hollywood sign right there i was supposed to have my own
round rushmore too but we didn't have time i know i just
love wow so i'm so humble guys i land all about me
um but there was supposed to be a mount rushmore or a mount
dokeymore behind dokeylon uh but we did yeah mount dokeymore
with uh the four founding dokeys uh yeah there's i will say
my only criticism in this world is that there's just not
enough dokeys i just feel like we lack we lack Doki's in
Doki La.
So, the Mount Rushmore of YouTubers.
No, it's the Mount Doki more of YouTubers.
It's going to be Doki, Doki, Doki, and Doki.
So, that's going to be a future update as well.
The Doki Sweet.
I'm super excited for all of you guys to explore Doki now
and yourself.
When this world goes public.
When will this world go public?
I don't know.
To be honest, because we have to add, fix some things in
this world before we let you guys, before we push it for
public release.
There are a few things we'll add, fix a bit.
There's one thing.
I don't know if the project team is watching right now.
I was going to type it out to you guys.
But after the stream, I think it would be better.
Um.
So here it is.
This is our little.
Our night mode.
Um.
You see the sun come down here.
It's really cool.
You see that sun come down?
I think it would be cooler.
If we have more stars out.
Um.
To make it more like.
More aesthetically.
Like it's like the.
The wild west night sky.
I think it would be really cool.
If we can have more stars out for that.
And also like.
I guess like a more like lighter like yeah oh constellations
that would be so cute if we have constellations um yeah like
the desert sky I think it'll be cool I think after the
stream I realized it'd be we have a Merry Christmas one
because originally it was for Christmas and I was like no
let's push it for New Year's so we do have Merry Christmas
if you want to spend Christmas in Doki Lod it's just like
Disney it's just like Disneyland oh yeah one of the biggest
things I had
huge change on the last month was that Dokilan was was first
no not the last month it was like two months ago we had to
where they um they were like everyone's panicking because I
was like why is it called Dokilan so um originally it was
called Dokilan because you know it was when um it was before
Some some bitch stole in Minecraft stole dokey land.
So I had to create dokey land
So it was before the incident so it was before the incident
so um somebody copyrighted dokey land in minecraft so I had
to pivot and then create dokey land so then I had to tell
the project 3d people I was like, we have to...
We have to adjust.
We have to adjust the name of this world.
It must be called Dokilan now.
Before the Minecraft incident.
So now we're officially called Dokilan.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, no crime was ever committed in Dokilan.
It's real now!
Dokilan is real!
Yeah, but when you're in this room, remember to tag your
screenshots with Doki-lon.
Yeah, the happiest place on earth.
I mean, there was never any witnesses.
What are you guys talking about?
Because I never committed any crime.
How can there be a crime?
How can there be witnesses if there's no crime?
crime guys how can there be witnesses if there was never any
crime
there's no war exactly there's never any war in dokyland
all right now
now that we finish looking at look at that I also got the
behind the scenes that the team drafted up for us compiled
for us all right let's me close this real quick
like I said this Doki Lan was the most hands-off I've been
for a VR project.
I gave it to the team, the project team, to come up with all
of the creative stuff side of Doki Lan, building it ground
up.
Because when I contacted everyone on this, my idea that I
gave, the idea proposed to them was that wanted like a wild
west theme and i want i do want a saloon that's heavily
based off of the background that i use for um you know uh
for my chatting screen um so that was like the initial
concept that i proposed to them so i wanted to be called
doki land you know before the minecraft incident uh at first
it was called doki land
needs a gold mat oh that's such a good idea we should get
the gold mat um harvesting the gold for a dokey land that's
where all your gold goes to uh um yeah and uh how did it
land online because someone else took dokey land i was
trying to establish dokey land uh in minecraft but someone
took dokeyland so now we have dokeyland
the legally distinct dokeyland is like when someone filed a
trademark of the like it's like someone filed a trademark of
like disneyland so now you have to create disneyland
yet they started that fire oh we do need a campfire area i
don't know if any of my project team is taking notes right
now i like that campfire area gold mines we need the
dragoons to farm some gold for the duchess of dokylan yeah
the dokylan in our hearts so dokylan so you can see
originally um i had to change some things around so I came
in to the world, like, I think, like, four times.
I gave, like, notes four times for a project that's been
around for half a year.
Because, like, I said, I was very hands-off for this one.
I let the team do this work on...
At first, there was no deadline.
I was just, like, just work at your own pace.
I want to create a...
I didn't want to, like...
I was going to work at your own pace and just construct
something.
And then I figured out when to debut it.
But then I realized, as the months go by...
I was like, I want to release this for new years.
I thought it was like a perfect time to do a new year's
countdown reveal for this because, you know, I haven't had,
you know, I don't haven't had like a VR chat world yet for
Dokeybird.
So, and I always wanted to do like these little official
meet and greets too in VR as well.
So I figured, you know, two years, almost two years have
passed.
I think this is the perfect time to debut a VR chat world
for everyone to visit, hangout and everything.
And VR chat is free, by the way, for those who don't know,
VR chat is free and you don't have to have VR to play in VR
chat.
So you can be on desktop mode, you can be on your PC.
I mean, I literally showed you guys Doki lot on PC.
So you don't need VR, you can also like play on your desktop
and everything.
Sadly, it's not on console.
That's the only downside.
It's to have a PC to be able to um to be able to boot up um
vr chat um but yeah so um huge childhood team like I said
during the last week and the last and yesterday um I gave
them a giant list of notes to change some things because
there are some things that like were like the final stretch
and they were able to like um they were able to like plow
through like majority of the notes that I gave So to make
the finalized version of Dokilan, so huge shout out to them
because like some of the things I asked for changes is like,
you can't see Dokilan very well.
Like the welcome sign and the Dokilan, like it's very hard
to see.
And then they changed all of that.
They made it more visible and everything.
So huge shout out to them for making some of these changes.
Here's them sketching.
Here's like concept art of them sketching out the world and
everything, like the layout
because I want it to be like a Wild West recreation, but
also like an amusement park and everything.
So here's the behind the scenes stuff.
Like I said, I was very hands off with this.
I gave them the initial concept idea.
And then like what I want.
I also wanted to include like the NPCs around like Dragon
NPCs and everything.
Like they're like cast members, you know?
Like the recreation cast members and everything.
Like we're at Disneyland type deal.
Or we're at Westworld.
Like those old, the Wild West recreation stuff.
And so I, like, they're them laying it out, the 3D
foundations of everything.
Some concept sketches, the statues.
So, you know, it's like the Walt Disney statue.
But it's me.
So, so, so the idea was for them.
I remember this.
I actually saw them, like, saw them, like, figuring this
out.
But it's basically like the Walt Disney statue where Walt
Disney is holding Mickey Mouse's hand.
That's like the front of the statue, like the front of the
amusement park.
And that's basically it.
So it's me.
And then more concept art of everything.
Doki bird.
Doki lawn.
Oh yeah, there you go.
Mount Doki more.
Dokeland before the Minecraft incident.
Before the Minecraft incident.
It used to be called Dokeland.
So there's Mount Dokemore.
We might have to get rid of Dad.
He's not a Doke.
I'll think about it.
want to include dad in the um it's not mount dadmore it's
maybe we'll have like a smaller a smaller dadmore somewhere
else he's in there but his name is oh that's your dokey
average doge yeah yeah but i was the first dokey like all
right no we'll keep dad i like this list i like i like this
list though mountain dokey more make him bigger he has to be
bigger all right so that oh i should have bgm give me a sec
i just realized there is no bgm playing do i have bgm oh my
god i don't know what there's a random bgm in there but it's
called rock bgm and i don't trust that i i have no idea what
exactly that bgm is So I don't trust whatever rock BGM is.
Oh, we'll do this.
Yeah.
All right, and here's some props.
Dokelaan Town.
So here's some of the props that were made.
It's a little, look, it's a little rundown, but we just
don't have the budget to refurbish some of the place here,
okay?
Like, we're literally in the desert, guys.
we're in the desert it's very hard to clean
so here is um some of the stuff for like the benches the
tables and the chairs it's really cute like the little the
little tablecloths and everything we should have since we
have several tables do you think we can add um other
tablecloths to the other ones that be really cute we should
add like other tablecloths too and then here's the street
lamp concepts right here it'll be cute and see who the
concept artist here as well don't worry i'll i'll paste the
link of the behind the scenes powerpoint too um in the
description for those who want to look at it themselves
slowly and then here's some uh photo op frames the original
concept bar they drew on paper oh my god so you can take
pictures like those like little photo ops that you see at
amusement parks and so there's like a little stands
everywhere scattered around oh and then there's a okay i
gotta show you guys this okay so um remember how said like
the original fireworks place we had we had like no picnic
area so they had to add that one in the last two days like
the last two days before before stream day before d day um
they had to add a picnic area because we i tested out the
fireworks concept i was like um guys we gotta fix this we
gotta either we have to remove the billboards or figure out
a way to show the show the fireworks because when i play the
fireworks this is what i I see.
I'm fucking, it just felt too dystopian at that point.
It felt like I truly am in Disneyland.
Like, it's like, what lovely fireworks.
Anyway, bye, mama.
So, that was like, when I, like, hop onto the world the last
two days, I was like, yeah, there was, like, ads everywhere.
Oh, shit, sorry.
Sorry, you heard that.
That was my...
base station don't worry it's okay i actually knocked over
the base station that tracked my legs um so we had to we
made the picnic area because of that and thank god we did
because that was definitely a better choice to have um so
yeah here it's okay yeah so the yeah i just saw like my pc
case at the bottom i was like guys we gotta fix that like um
I don't know if I like that.
What's another thing I want to show you guys?
Oh, here.
Let me save it.
I didn't save this.
Yeah, bye-bye, Mitch.
So they moved the, thankfully, they moved the billboards to
another location.
Oh, there's also hidden items.
You might be able to find hidden items scattered around,
too, that I didn't show you guys.
But there's some little hidden Easter eggs.
too around the world oh and then here's like this is like
their idea because that we were like we gotta we gotta
figure out a way uh to be able to watch the fireworks so the
project team in two days constructed the picnic area right
here so shout out to them for like building an extra zone
last so last minute too uh but yeah here's all the
billboards you might be able to find around the world the
advertisements the subliminal messages um some of the custom
billboards as well um that you'll see join the elite dragon
academy be the nerd you were meant to be dude what's right
yeah which dokey will you choose and then here is uh some of
the gravestone concepts that we have here the different
designs of the dragon graveyard yeah 401 dokey coins what a
fucking steal right here and then uh we're debating i
remember they were debating on what to do like who's who's
the main grave and um the team uh the team voted on the
minecraft thing I mean, it was a good choice Rick, thank you
for the super chat Thank you, thank you Hi, Doki, thanks for
the stream Can I recommend you a song?
It's called White Ferrari by Frank Ocean It's a happy song,
it's so good Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank
you Of course, I'll check it out after the stream Thank you
so much for the super chat Oh, I need to use the bastion
real quick, guys I will be right back, everybody
I'm back Uh Factor!
I need, like, put away all my VR stuff.
I'll open up this right now.
And also, takes up a lot of power, so I don't want to...
I don't need to waste more electricity.
I don't want to do that enough as being a streamer.
But yes, I'm back.
Factor, Rio, Jaila Kong, Kat is me.
Kat and Smug, Juge, Nexi, Papa, Smurf, Buzz, Aphelia, Neper,
Solid, Medi, and Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
really appreciate it guys thank you so much um but yeah like
i said this world is like accumulation of my career as jokie
bird so you know this is like a nice throwback to like all
the streams that we did all the little inside jokes the lore
that we established uh throughout the years of streaming so
i figured you know it was really cute that they decided on
you know the minecraft the minecraft pig as the as the
tombstone uh originally there wasn't actually a pop-up of
the ghost it was really a ghost like the there was you saw
the right like the regular dragon there be like oh it's so
sad please play blah blah blah blah soundtrack um yeah of
rubin um um but then i wanted to do like that little the
little oh shit um the little like jump scare of a ghost
popping up and disappearing when you get closer i thought it
was like a really cool idea just i think it was really cool
makes it more interesting interactive.
Here is the tomato farm.
The infamous farm that you all join the membership for.
When you join the membership, you start, you have the
wonderful opportunity to work on the farm.
That's right.
You pay me to work on the tomato farm.
so there it is and it's a great experience too you get to
see what it's like to work on the farm guys no this is not
where you guys spot this is where i spot my army yeah
welcome to the tomato fields and here are all the other
signs for the other different shops and locations located
around so there's the dps bank crocus emporium so originally
it was established they wrote it as established 2020 and
then um i was like when i saw that on the saloon i was like
why is it 2020 like i didn't know the reference because they
picked the year um also you can tell that i like i also
adjusted this i was like make this red and make this part
green because then it's like more And they're like, oh, we
don't remember why.
Because I was like, so why did you pick the year 2020?
I'm like a bit confused.
Like, I feel like, am I missing something about my own
career?
And they're like, oh, we don't remember why we picked 2020.
I was like, oh, it's a five.
You can just pick the, you can pick like the year I debuted.
And then a couple of days later, I came back.
And I was like, guys, so why is it on 2023?
And like, that's the year you came back.
And I was like, guys, that's 2024.
And I saw that on the day of the stream in the morning when
I went to do like the final sweep around the world.
We're like, oh fuck, we're off by a year.
So, yeah, so, I literally, yeah, I was like, it was like the
morning, it was like the morning of the 31st, and I was just
like, guys, I don't, so, so, what, what year, what was the,
why is it 2023?
So, we were able to fix that last minute, so now you see
2020.
24 on the salute.
All right, and then there's some more of the Dokilan
buildings.
Like I said, for the future updates, we're going to make
them so that you can enter the buildings and stuff.
We got to come up with the concept of how they should look
like them.
That's like our next task.
Man, here's like the rough design, Western and futuristic.
Oh, it's like, oh yeah, their inspiration was Junkertown
from Overwatch.
So, if you guys were like, oh, it just looks like
Junkertown.
That's where they grabbed a lot of their inspiration from.
But also, I asked them to, like, add a window.
So for the jail on the side, I asked them to, like, add a
window so you could see one of the locked-up dragons just,
like, on the bars, being, like, let me out.
I want you to see the criminal.
What else is there?
Oh, yes.
Here's some concept art.
of what the jail should look like.
And in the end, it's just him.
I like the taped sunglasses.
Yeah, see that?
The taped sunglasses on the Dragoon.
We should make a Sheriff Goon.
We should make that Sheriff Goon, too.
Smart.
And then here's the DPS.
Here's the concept sketches of what the bank would look
like.
savings.
So this is from Allet.
I'm super glad it made it through.
Dragons will know the instant they see it.
Joki always mentions how she loves to include us in things
and this was a way for me to really help with that.
Thank you for being such an amazing community and I made you
proud.
So this is from Allet.
Concept art from Allet and then the 3D gear and then Wuka
doing the logo for DPS savings.
And here is Shell Shock.
Can't be a western town if there's no ammo for shooting we
try to include as many different dragon types as possible
and this one is for egg goons get it ha ha shell shock shell
egg how is he with his feet of course how is the egg he's
using his foot to grip on the gun but here's all like all
the different types of um quick draw armory oh i wish we
could have done the like you know walk there like with
snuffy and i did the i wish snuffy and i would did that
where like we're like we did a western duel and we like walk
10 like turn around and walk 10 steps back and then draw but
like i said we had no time it would have been fun if we were
able to get a showdown an old classic western showdown with
guns yeah
technically we can in the future also they made tumbleweeds
they're gonna add it in later and there's a croaky emporium
concept artist by outlet
and in other signs that didn't make the cut the welcome sign
went through a bit and I felt upright to be greeted by
everyone.
It wouldn't be a Doki world.
The truth start underneath all the skin soup.
Home sweet home in the tomato farm.
Lastly, we remembered the Doki Lawn incident of 2025.
What Doki Lawn incident?
I don't know what you're talking about.
This graveyard has nothing to do with any incidents that
happened in Doki Lawn.
You signed, you clicked accept on the terms of conditions
guys.
Wait, did the graveyard his own sign?
I didn't even notice.
that.
Oh no, they're okay.
Whoa.
Oh yeah.
So these are all the, yeah, what Dokilan incident?
I have no idea what any of them are talking about.
What incident?
Yeah, here's all the concept art of the graveyard, the farm,
and the welcome set.
And then we have our water tower, because Because a western
town has to have a water tower to get the water.
So, yeah.
So the overall water supply.
And we can see the different concept art of the water tower.
Yay!
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck is this?
This top.
I don't know.
I've never seen that sketch before.
No, what the fuck is this thing at the top?
This thing.
What an odd creature.
Man, there's the Doki Lan water tower.
And then here's the water tower logo.
Right here.
Yeah, you sell Doki Lan.
Yeah, they had to...
Yeah, it was...
I did like that this is originally Doki Lan.
Before the Minecraft.
Minecraft situation.
Yeah, Doki Lime.
And then some windmill as well.
Oh yeah, there's a windmill here.
We almost had a beak fan that opened and closed.
Maybe in the future.
I'll be so cool!
That'll be cool if we were able to add that.
I didn't know it'd be really immersive.
You guys can add it.
But here is the windmill.
You can see it at the um You can see it at the, I think it
like near the graveyard of Doki Lan.
And the game boosts.
I like the gun idea.
That was really cool.
So here's the different concept designs of the gun.
Unfortunately, we were not able to play any of the games.
Like I said, we were on a very tight schedule.
We didn't want to miss the countdown.
I refuse to do my countdown.
The Shaw Goodman fucking room.
I...
So, but I hope you guys are able to enjoy the games when the
world goes public.
Like I said, the Sloppy Sisters are going to be doing an
official meet and greet in the Doki Lan world.
Dates and time will be announced later when we align our
schedules.
Because, you know, all four of us are like, you know, really
busy people, all four of us.
So, you know what's crazy?
I did not get a DMCA on the Saul Goodman fucking...
worlds but i got dmca because the the the plane world had
top gun music in there so so i can't so the so unfortunately
the video is unmonetizable because of it because of the
fucking top gun slash europe yeah i got a fucking dmca from
that but the song goodman world was fine it was fine
Yeah, so these are like, there's the dunk the dunk tank, the
whack-a-bullet, and also the little, like, you know those,
like, clown ones where you shoot, like, water into the
clown, and then whoever shoots the most water in it wins.
For this one, the more you shoot water in it, the more the
neck grows.
So here's all the game boosts and everything.
yeah it does it actually goes up the more water you shoot
yeah the balloon race the more water you shoot into the doki
the longer the neck grows and then here's the all the
there's black moon dragon moon duncan and bang bang how long
does it get well you gotta play play to fight oh and this is
based off of my water gun from my um from my summer debut My
summer outfit.
My summer is skin suit.
So this is the water gun design from it.
And then there's hit, hit, bang, bang.
Yeah, and then there's some of the dragon NPCs.
The drunk one I asked them to add it during one of my
feedback sessions.
I was like, we must have a drunk dragon.
No, sorry.
A very sober dragon in front of the saloon.
So I'm glad they added that.
nice it was a nice touch it makes the world more real you
know it makes the world feel more real and more like i felt
wanted to feel like a small town like a natural like you
know um recreate like um like those like interactable oh my
god oh no no okay i gotta get tissue i did not see it there
are there is ranch dressing on my on my gaming mouse pad out
of the container and i didn't notice oh no oh 2026 is
starting out great for dokey because it's i can oh that's a
lot of rats oh no that's oh no it got on the keyboard
because i flipped the tissue oh no give me oh what a great
start i accidentally flipped it it was a lot of wrench oh i
might have to order a new gaming mouse pad oh i don't know
how long the wrench has been marinating
oh oh that's bad i might have to order a new one I actually
might That sucks Because these mouse pads are expensive
Just wash it I don't know Because like This is like a gaming
mouse pad So like the fabric is much more sensitive Than a
regular The fabric is much more sensitive Than You can't
really wash it Like I said It's much more sensitive It's not
glass pad Than like a regular mouse pad because of how
sensitive the it is uh i might i'm gonna grab a towel and
soak it in water real quick i'll be right back
guys it's so noticeable that ranch dressing was on my i'm
gonna take a picture it's so noticeable
oh god don't guess you guys Do you think you can tell where
red dressing was?
Let me show you guys a picture.
Guys, is it...
Is it bad, guys?
Does it look bad, guys?
Oh,
dumb.
Curse you, Americana Sabachi!
Craven Because I had a craving for hot wings
Okay, guys, I want you guys to be honest with me
I want you guys to be honest I want you guys to be honest
Alright,
that's it let's minimize this it does not have the picture
does not have to be that big
guys it doesn't look that bad right
guys you can barely tell right
it doesn't it's okay right it doesn't look that bad right
chat thank you for the super chat thank you thank you who's
that pokemon
that's the ghost of a lot of good thank you for the super
chat pop up money for the doom guys guys do you think it's
salvageable guys we're going to thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you i'm so sad what a way to start 2026 oh
my god i didn't realize my wrench was spilling out
I really did.
Alright.
But anyway, let's go back.
Let's go back to to the fucking NPCs.
Some money for a new mouse.
Thank you for the Akka Super Forward.
Thank you.
I got you.
Thanks for everything you do, Doki.
Looking forward to what you got in Surface.
This is your thank you.
Thank you for funding me my new mouse bed.
I really appreciate it.
Forward.
Thank you for the Akka Super but it really beats a lot.
This is why you should keep tissues fired.
I did!
I forgot I went and wiped it as fast as possible.
I don't know how long it sat marinating my fucking mouse
pad, right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I literally looked down and I noticed a pool of wrench on my
fucking mouse pad.
Anyway, are some dragoons, some NPCs, so they're...
Oh, we should wait.
We don't have... Wait, wait.
Can we add?
Can we add the egg waders?
That's so cute.
I just noticed that.
I want to add the egg waders there.
Can we add that later?
No, I know.
I didn't miss it, guys.
I did.
I know what.
I am not enabling
I'm Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She's so cute.
Did you play more Dynasty Warriors relationship cutscenes?
I think in the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, I like a bunch of the other other NPC concept
art.
Wait, we did have them!
Wait, we do have them!
Wait, where's the waiter egg going?
We should add them in.
let's add the waiter it's so cute we actually have the 3d
models of it I didn't know they were not in the saloon I
don't think so I didn't see them in the saloon but we should
add them add the waiter uh solid snake thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you that's GG's for your 2026 and
2027 here we go don't get me a washing machine new mouse
back fun thank you the super chat solid.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much.
And then here's the stage.
Like I said, you guys can watch my streams, you know?
We do a little watch party.
When we're doing, like, watch alarms or stuff or watch
parties, you guys will be able to do, like, a watch party in
the VI chat world with all the other dragons and stuff.
It'll be so fun.
That's why I always say, like, whenever we make worlds, I
like to have, like, a TV there.
Like, TV in all the worlds.
Like, a stage or a TV.
like for all the dragoons that hang out together we're doing
a hangout party or session and we're not you're not using my
world to watch saw goodman that is my only rule all right
project team if you are watching put a sign um i would like
a sign there that says saw goodman is ban it banned from
this premises i feel like if you see this man Do not let him
in.
Like, I would like to have a sign where it's just to face a
Saul Goodman and then you cross him out.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
It's like, he is bad.
Yeah, a wanted sign for Saul Goodman.
And if it's a wanted sign, it'd be like dead, not alive.
like what a dead no lawyers are allowed on this premise here
you go and then there's the stages the concept art for the
stages how i end up yeah so originally there was this art
there on the side and i said please move it i was just like
um i do not feel comfortable having buba blobfish on the
side of the stage Please move him somewhere else.
So we moved the blobfish somewhere else.
Bonus point.
If it saw Goodman, fan art cross.com.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And we're more on the concept art and the 3D of the stage
itself.
And then the saloon.
Here's the saloon.
Exterior.
Like I said, that was a mandatory thing.
I was like, If anything, I dip, I, the mad, sorry.
I need the saloon in this world.
That was the one thing I needed in the world.
Rayblade, thank you for the super chat.
Do you think that's the most in-character thing you've ever
said?
There's red jump on my gamer mouse pad.
Usually, I've been trying to avoid eating at my desk.
So, like, of course, I get punished because I was like, Oh,
fuck, I have a stream.
I have a stream soon.
I gotta go.
I gotta eat at my desk.
Here's the more of the concept art of the saloon and
everything.
And then here is the logo for it.
The Dragoon Saloon.
Except...
Yeah, 2020, 2023.
I like it's like the correct one.
Guys, third time's the try, you know?
Third time's the one.
In case you forget, this is the correct one.
In the end, it's okay.
Three times the charm.
Yeah, so here's the logo for it as well.
Ragoon Saloon.
The numbers, what do they mean?
That was me!
I was like, what did the numbers be?
I was like, why is it?
I was like, I'm confused.
Why did we pick 2020, 2020, and 2023?
And in the interior of the saloon.
I think it's really cool that when you can, like, go into
the building too.
So here are some of the food.
They weren't able to make all the food.
I would love to have you guys made the bento box as well.
well for the future update.
I think the bar looks amazing.
The design of the bar, it looks so good.
Yeah, so here's like the bar and everything.
The little jukebox, the saloon jukebox.
Here's like all the design.
So yeah, it looks like Do Kitty.
The jukebox was based off of Do Kitty and everything.
Like I said, it's very personalized, like everything.
And then here are all the drinks and stuff, the bar bottles,
the dragon shine, 45% alcohol, busting, and doking beer from
my background.
I was like, we have to have doking beer since 2024.
Like, that one was right.
Wait, wait, guys, guys, okay.
So, wait, project team.
So, like, how did we get that 2024 correct?
on the Toe King beer.
Look, at least we got the 2024 on the Toe King beer.
At least we got that one correct.
Beer was more important.
No, this was before.
I corrected the 2024, like, the day of the stream.
It was like literally the day of the stream.
Oh, and then there's furniture.
We love furniture here.
We're not good with years, bro.
It's always a bureau clock somewhere in the world.
Like, oh my god, look at this chair, though!
And the table!
Oh my god!
table right there.
That's a sexy table.
Look at those polygons and those textures.
Wow.
Beautiful.
And then here is the wall mount.
I want you guys to know those are, this is an ass by the
way, in case you're wondering, those, that's the butt, okay?
It's, it says juicy, okay?
That's,
else.
It's the ass.
It's the buttocks and nothing else.
Yeah, the 3DT made this from scratch.
They're dragon cheeks.
But yes, this is a dragon that did not pay his taxes.
So remember dragons.
To pay the doki tax and the dragoon.
There's several taxes you gotta pay.
So you know how there's like sales tax and like your GST and
your other T's.
So there's the dragoon tax and your doki tax.
So remember to pay those taxes or you're going to end up
like this guy.
We're going to get both your backs too.
We're going to get the front and the back.
We can't waste good body parts.
But stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The chongers' nesticles are how good to see.
We have that reference there.
And here's the food design.
Um, I don't know why you guys keep...
There's the rice maker, the rice cooker, um, there's some
doki-la and sandwiches, and the doki burger.
It's just like Disneyland.
We should have churros.
Project team, we should have Churros.
It'll be the true, it'll be just like Disneyland.
And then like, if we, we should have a Churros stand.
All right, Project team, write this down.
We need to have a Churros stand and the Churros must cost
$10.
There should be a sign and be like $10.
Yoko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, no, they should be $20.
You're right.
The Churros stand has to be $20.
per churro truly is disneyland but better it's just like
disney here's my feet please don't hang me i'm in the wall
turkey thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yoko
wait go back oh now you want ten dollars it's too late you
complained about ten dollars i was like you're right it
should have been twenty it'll be twenty dollar per churro
and don't And here are the trinkets, the little, like,
decorations.
Oh, yeah, you guys can see the playing cards were also
customized and everything.
So you can see the little, all the cute little trinkets
around and everything.
I really like the little sloppy hats to, as, like, a little,
what's the word, like, commemorate our first collab
together.
But yeah, there's, like, all the other trinkets that they
designed.
here that didn't make it to the cut like i said there was a
time limit um everyone was like okay when i was like okay
guys we have until new years for this world now so then they
had to you know they had to cut some things out to make it
in time for the new year's update or the new year's debut uh
sleepy thank you the super chat thank you thank you dragon
rice cooker merch when thank you the super chat thank you
thank you yeah because when i first when i first did the
sloppy sisters collab um i wore a little crusty crab hat uh
for it and it's a little throwback it was a little throwback
to that stream and then here's the oh yeah there were cigars
there i didn't get managed to like i forgot to like pick it
up but you guys can you guys can smoke legally smoking
myself isn't it great cigars for everyone for all ages um
but only if you're in disneyland though don't worry only
nylon.
Yeah, you can smoke inside, outside, as long as you're in
Doki-lon.
And then there's the crane games.
I think cranes are always a classic to have in the world.
So it's cool that we also got to add the crane games again.
And then like the design for it and everything.
And the little had and the logos as well.
The Doki's bounties.
And then there's like decals on all the machines and
everything.
Oh yeah.
There is a game cabinet that works in here.
It's called...
It's basically like Pong.
So, um, it's it's basically Pong.
Um, what's it called?
Tomagan?
Um, so you can play Pong in my world!
Um, um so and these are the other cabinets that we have in
this world as well we have dan and dad detective dragon
freak or treat and tomagon yay little arcade machines at the
saloon and then we have uh a dartboard as well that you can
play there's darts and playing cards for the dragons and
then there's do ten dookotendo cube um not not related to
anything else I would like to say parody law.
So we added a bunch of...
They added a bunch of the Doki Jam cover art.
Completely original.
Trademarked by Doki.
No relations to anything else.
But we added some...
You guys made a lot of amazing games for the Game Jam.
And we added some of your games into the world as well.
They're you're gaming our world and here's like a bunch of
the cover art Lolly they give the super chat they can think
I have no idea what you're talking about and also um at the
saloon There's also like I think I think outlet was very
inspired by This particular artwork that I'm trying to show
you guys, but Gotta disappear for a sec.
I think outlet was very inspired in one particular artwork
for the wall mount i'm unsure which one it is at the moment
uh so um there are in the saloon there's several portraits
that you can find uh that you'll be able to find scattered
around the saloon and these are some of the things that they
included here and then the fbs level unfortunately this was
incomplete um like i said there was a lot of stuff to do so
this was one things that they were not able to finalize in
the end um and it was the fps game that we have that was uh
basically inspired by battle birds from my first from my
bounty hunter debut so there's a map layout of everything
that you can see here so here's the concept art so like
where like everything was gonna be at and how everything was
gonna be placed and screenshots of all the
versus oh I saw something funny that they posted in the
server let me see if I can grab it um oh yeah you know how I
was talking about like I realized that I was like wait a
minute this game already has a name look I was very busy I
didn't realize okay I didn't realize because like that that
was an oversight on my end as well because I'm like the
final check and then I didn't real then the final check I
didn't notice it so it was a little oversight on my part but
it was also a group effort oversight though like we all
forgot it was a group effort oversight it wasn't it was a
group work and I saw them you know how I mentioned I was
like guys we gotta figure out how to like so I saw them post
this in the server, so it's like But the logo's sick though
So I was like, put it at the bottom We don't have to Yeah,
it was a group failure
I thought that's actually really funny But then the logo was
We just have the logo in the back You know, we got the logo
shown in the back Because there is the backside But then the
front we put the sign on I think that'll be good and then
that'll be funny write that down project team the backside
will have the actual the original logo and then the front
side will be the battle birds and then cardboard on top of
it
we're like oh yeah we forgot about that yeah the game got
realized but it is an amazing logo shout out to wuka for the
logo and then here's like the ui of it you'll understand it
when it's when the when we release it um and here are the
designs for the dokylon fps level and now we're at the
extras oh my gosh we're almost to the end of this so the
extras that the crew made yeah came yeah we came out of beta
and we put new name
the here are the different oh yeah so um there was gonna be
a uh the do do do the do the scat like um in the world but
it felt really weird as just like um as just there so i was
like just put it as a portrait and the saloon so the la dodo
is gonna be a portrait somewhere i figured that It felt
weird.
It felt so...
It looked so out.
Oh, and then there's the Sloppy Sisters.
There's like a bunch of graffiti scattered around.
Scattered around the world.
What else?
Oh, here's more graffiti.
That's everywhere.
Looks pretty fucking sick.
And then here is...
It's the garrison.
The tabloids and the...
The dragoon yaoi.
I like the tabloid.
Thirsty dragoon causing deadly water shortage.
A dragoon caught with another mascot.
An idle constant.
Wardrobe malfunction shocks the nation.
You have anything...
Oh wait, that's Will.
Will, that...
Will and Owlet.
I want to ask, what's up with you guys and dragoon asses?
What?
What's up with your fascination with the dragoons behind?
And then here is Owlet's covers.
Owlet's book covers.
It's just beautiful.
What can we say?
and then here are there's some the dating sim there's like
dating sim billboard scattered or uh oh they didn't know we
were they had to cut that out but we're they're planning on
adding that back in um extra extra ads for you guys so you
know there was a logo made for it but it'll be added back in
so don't worry so um the man of your dreams yeah which jokie
will you love bird doki heart and an unused concept so
there's a church wait I should love this idea we should add
the church the lasagna church
actually I think I yeah we have to add the church of lasagna
guys we have to that's that's something alright gold mines
churrosan the lasagna church and What was my other idea that
I wanted?
What was the other one that we wanted, chat?
We had another one.
finally, it's like the spaghetti monster religion.
But this is better.
We're not here for spaghetti.
We're here for lasagna.
No, not more dragon butts.
Campfire.
Project team.
Write that down.
And then, oh my god, we could have had a doggy bed.
But here are like Oh, Dad's Kids The sloppy meal The dad
burger Better than me Dragoon egg and ham salad Special
sauce Dad approved Doki's burrito bowl It tastes normal
So some more unused concept Like the Dad toys and the Dad
bed And then there's like The branding Doki La tomato it's
like McDonald's but dokey line and then here are here are
the wanted posters that this is not all the wanted posters
we made there's more that you could find in the world as
well we had some more as well so if you look around there's
like wanted posters scattered around the floor the walls and
everything so yeah and you can create your own too if you
want to they added the template If you want to create your
own wanted poster.
And then there are some bloopers that they have their fun in
the server.
What I love about doing these projects is just seeing, you
know, a bunch of people coming together and, like, just
working together for one thing.
And it's really cool to see everyone bonding and stuff in.
Yeah, cake.
And, you know, becoming friends and, um, becoming friends
with each other and, you know, uh, creating something
amazing together.
And brainstorming ideas.
Uh, here's some stuff that, ah, okay, wait.
Ask Dragoon, bracket, owl, bracket.
All right.
and some discord leaks some stuff in the discord it's like
yeah like you can get sincere they have their little meeting
rooms and stuff um it's gone guys the whole thing
the fucking thing just it's gone guys
it's crazy Yeah, they got into They got into a little bit
Into Uma Musume In the middle of the project Yeah, they
started talking about Uma Musume
And what else What else is in the...
Oh yeah, and then they were researching Yowie for For
research, of course They were out there Trying to figure out
how to make Yowie, I guess And then Then they, yeah, they
had to do, apparently they did a playtest session where they
got, what the fuck?
Where the fuck did Godzilla show up?
Okay, so Godzilla made a visit to Dokila.
Yeah, quote-unquote research.
Yeah, the king of monsters.
Legally distinct, Godzilla.
Yeah, God... See, I told you guys.
Dokilan is so popular, guys.
Come visit Dokilan.
Godzilla went.
Look at that.
We got a vouch from Godzilla.
And here's more playtest.
Here's more Uma Musume from the crew.
And that's all this lies.
All right, so here is everyone that worked incredibly hard
throughout the last couple of months from the entire project
team.
Like I said, so the project leader is Joule, otherwise known
as Kusako.
And then there's the 3D team is Squid, Ores, Salted Fish,
Legends, and Haske.
You might recognize all of these people.
We have worked with them many, many times in the past.
A huge shout out to the 3D team and Entity.
He was also...
Entity and Kusako were both the cameraman goons as well in
the world.
So they stayed up the entire stream to work on the cameras
for the world as well.
So a huge shout out to them.
And then here are the concept artists and the graphics and
the 3D models team.
So we have Will, Jim.
and allette they did the concept art uh naki wuka and orca
did the logos orca came in literally two days before the
world the stream debuted because i needed and i needed an
actual logo for it like like as if like you know we're at an
amusement park type deal that's why i was like emergency
doesn't we need a logo maker right now so orca made the
dokylan logo in the end for us so uh they They came in
clutch.
And then Naki and Wuka did all the other logos and the type
setting here.
And then Katsumi, Ryu, and Rika did the 3D model art.
Like the concept art from Katsumi and Katsumi.
And then Ryu and Rika for making the 3D models as well for
the Sloppy Sisters.
So a huge shout out to everyone.
I will be posting a description.
Posting in the description of this PowerPoint.
so everyone can look into the PowerPoint themselves and
check out all the amazing talented work beautiful work that
the whole team did.
This project like I said was in the works for since July or
June I don't remember.
Oh I wanted to show you guys this so one of the things, one
of my feedback that I gave them was I felt like it was so
like the world felt a little too empty.
Um because like um here's something that i gave as feedback
as well as um so originally you can tell that um there was
it was just like this um this was like a week before like i
think it was like four to five days before the stream and
this was like a big criticism criticisms i had during the
feedback session where i felt like it just felt like super
empty and there was like just a lot of space around the
world and after that when you go into the world you might
notice like that's so different like it um it's not like
that anymore um you can see from here too like it was so
empty where it was just like just a rat like just sand
texture and that's why it felt it feels more alive now so i
had just like put some dragons there some more NPCs
scattered around um some like you know stuff sticking out of
the sand because it's fucking sand sand is very annoying so
so they added all of that they added like rocks sand there's
gonna be tumbleweeds added in too later on um and everything
so um it was like a huge refurbishment um in in just like
four to five days that teams did that the project team did
so huge shout out to them for um being able to implement all
of that like so quickly um yeah so it feels more alive which
is something that um i wanted i wanted to feel like a lot
more alive and it felt like you know it felt like something
like it felt like an actual world that you think can exist
other than the whole like creepy uh life-size uh chickens
running around uh by creepy i meant like you know I would be
scared if I saw Dragoons like actual giant chickens that
could potentially crush me in the real world running around
what chickens we are dragons yeah It's alright.
Lovely giant chickens in the real world.
In an amusement park.
And also that can speak the human language.
But yeah, like I said, I wanted to make this world felt a
lot.
I think the team was able to accomplish that too.
It felt so like, you know, going into the world, from where
it started to where it is now, it's like from zero to a
hundred.
Like there are so many things they added in that they were
able to do so in such a short amount of time to just like
make it feel more immersive and more alive and less empty.
So like I said, yay, congratulations to the project team for
their incredible hard work.
When's the next update?
Here's several questions I think you guys might have.
What's the next update?
When will the world be public?
The next update, I am unsure.
Like I said, it really depends on the team themselves.
I think they deserve a nice break right now.
Right now, before they go into another, you know, before
they go into another session.
And, you know, I want them to, I'll figure out another dead
left.
It'll be, maybe it'll be a special event.
It'll be for an anniversary.
No, not an anniversary.
That's way too soon.
Maybe it'll be for a birthday.
Maybe it'll be for like Christmas, Halloween, like a, or
maybe it'll be for another new year countdown.
Who knows?
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
There's a lot of things I want to add.
And, you know, it takes time to cook something amazing for
all of you guys.
ruin asses i think you that i'm the wrong person to ask i
think you gotta ask alette about that and will and when will
this world be public like i said there are a few things we
gotta fix real quick um but i will let you guys know as soon
as i can um maybe maybe it'll be a week maybe it'll take
around a week or so uh but we will see um there's a little
some minor things that I do want to tweak and want to add
into the world that we weren't able to add before.
But we'll aim for the end of next week to make a public
release.
But yeah, I think that's everything.
I think that's everything.
I hope you guys enjoyed the behind the scenes of Dokilon.
The happiest place on earth.
And also the most expensive.
And also...
Definitely the most expensive place on earth.
I think my favorite part is just adding the Easter eggs and
stuff.
It's just nice to see.
I have so many tabs, guys.
I'm trying to find my streaming tab.
I was like, where did I start my stream?
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
I found my streaming tab.
Yeah, no, I think I might have to buy another.
I might have to buy another mouse pad.
I tried using soap and to rub it off.
I don't know.
I think it's cooked, guys.
Why buy a one-day pass when you can buy a year past the
dokeelon?
Just like those Disney passes.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
It'll pay itself off, guys.
And while you're at it, you should also get it.
the Fast Pass too The Dokilan Fast Pass And also book your
stay at the Dokilan Hotel And remember to get your Dokilan
parking passes too Parking is very hard at Dokilan Yeah, why
not exactly Why not a Lifetime Pass too?
Oh, I like your style Girl, I like your style I like how you
think Yeah, Dokilan VIP Wait, what is that Disneyland VIP
The exclusive Disneyland VIP thing called Where like um you
have to pay like an x amount of membership fees and um it's
like super fucking exclusive that's like only like which
only like really uh really rich people or celebrities can
get into
club 33 club guys make sure to join club 69 for the doke lan
exclusives
Oh no, my god, 3D, like clear expedition, expedition.
I almost said the other one.
I was this close to saying it.
Club 8,000 and 8,000, honestly, club 8,000 and 8, guys.
boob one singular boob
yeah but you gotta pay for that pay up if you want to join
the club 8000 and 8 from Doki Lod you get your exclusive
exclusive Doki Lod merch with more Dragoon asses
yeah one's all you need
that was fun though that was really fun i'm glad to show you
guys all the hard work um of the project team for this world
um i was very like i said i was very hands-off for this one
uh um compared to the other worlds i've done in the past um
only because i've been very very busy in 2025 a lot of stuff
has happened to me for 2025 um so i delegated the world a
lot to the team as well as my staff members as well so but
in the end the world came out amazing um and everyone worked
incredibly high and i cannot wait for you dry wounds to be
able to experience the world yourself and see all the things
that i didn't show you guys like discover new things in the
world that i didn't show you guys too um anyway guys i'm
gonna call it here we do have another stream tonight um in
two hours all like maybe less than two hours in that an hour
and a half uh for uh the finale of haiti's two we're gonna
finally finish haiti's two today um so i'm gonna have to
call it here uh i hope you guys have a wonderful day as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.